[Música]
y comenzamos revista de prensa con
nuestra compañera Rosa Pérez más deu
Rosa buen viernes para usted y
bienvenida Buenos días María Clara bueno
Comencemos hablando de un artículo de
cena altayán en alyasira titulado raids
israelíes Por qué matan a tantos
palestinos a propósito de lo que ha
ocurrido y de los 30 palestinos que al
menos han fallecido en lo poco que va
del año efectivamente María Clara y como
bien decías no estos 30 fallecidos en lo
poco que va de año en este enero de 2023
sumados a los a 200 palestinos
asesinados por las fuerzas israelíes en
2022 uno de los años más mortíferos
según los registros de Naciones Unidas
en los territorios palestinos bien este
artículo establece que la violencia sin
embargo se intensificó a partir de 2021
a raíz de la represión israelí no sé si
recuerdas a las protestas por el
desplazamiento el desalojamiento de las
familias del barrio de Jake jarra en
Jerusalén este también por el bombardeo
israelí sobre la franja de gaza en la
que murieron en más de 250 palestinos
entre ellos varios menores y también
unos a 10 israelíes pues como
consecuencia de los cohetes disparados
desde la franja de gaza hasta
territorios de Israel por otro lado
también en 2022 recordemos que hubo otra
ofensiva israelí sobre la franja de gaza
en este caso murieron alrededor de 50
personas palestinas también señala este
artículo que Israel ha intensificado sus
arredadas en genining centros de la
resistencia Palestina y que en estas
redadas a menudo mueren civiles personas
que no necesariamente forman parte de
los grupos de resistencia Palestina y
también menores o periodistas recordemos
el caso de sheeran abuagle la reportera
de alllas irá precisamente que murió
asesinada el mayo de 2022 Rosa y a
propósito de este repunte de las redadas
y de las ofensivas también han aumentado
los grupos palestinos que se oponen a la
ocupación israelí Cuáles son esos grupos
efectivamente muchos de estos nuevos
grupos están integrados por jóvenes como
decíamos en los noticieros que no han
conocido otra vida que la vida bajo la
ocupación ilegal de Israel y algunos no
de estos nuevos grupos son las brigadas
de genil las brigadas de nablus o La
Guarida de los leones de la que tanto
escuchamos hablar últimamente no cada
vez estos grupos ofrecen una mayor
respuesta a las redadas israelíes o a la
ocupación israelí respondiendo no de
forma armada y organizada ante esta red
hadas y también pues organizando ataques
contra Soldados del ejército israelí
contra Checkpoints etcétera bueno Y
también estamos ante otro contexto Y es
que estamos con el gobierno israelí más
ultraderechista que ha habido en los
últimos años con unas alianzas con Ultra
ortodoxos judíos y que además
pretenden ampliar la ocupación en los
territorios palestinos Cuáles son las
perspectivas entonces con este gobierno
de Benjamín detallado bien este artículo
señala que si bien las perspectivas se
agravan no por todo lo que tú comentabas
hay que recordar que también bajo el
gobierno del centrista y a ir lapic los
las redadas y los asesinatos eran
también una política de estado para
Israel y cuáles son las reacciones a
esta redadas Pues recordemos que
organizaciones internacionales como
human right internacional incluso de
Naciones Unidas Y por supuesto la
población civil Palestina critica
reprocha no la impunidad de estar
redadas y de estos asesinatos para los
que los soldados israelíes a menuda no
rinden cuentas y también a sobre todo no
en las situaciones en casos en que las
víctimas mortales son menores o también
periodistas no que intentan pues sacar a
la luz lo que es el día a día bajo la
ocupación israelí cambiamos de
información Rosa porque el fiscal
general de Rusia calificó un medio
independiente medusa como indeseable
Cuáles son las implicaciones que esto
trae bien Este esta calificación de
indeseable lo que prohíbe de facto son
las operaciones de cualquier
organización extranjera porque este
medio medusa recordemos que está formado
por periodistas rusos pero está basado
en riga en letonia bien prohíbe las
operaciones de este medio entonces en
territorio Ruso y también persigue con
penas que pueden llegar hasta la prisión
cuatro años de prisión a los a las
personas que vivan en territorio ruso o
que sean rusas que participen con este
medio de comunicación y la participación
María Clara puede ser exclusivamente
compartir links compartirte pdfs con
artículos no de este medio de
comunicación o dar dinero a este medio
de comunicación Rosa y por qué están
llegando estas restricciones si te
parece María clara escuchemos al editor
general del medio hablamos de Iván queda
su versión no su interpretación de esta
nueva calificación expresada no
decretada por el fiscal general de Rusia
medusa fue bloqueada en Rusia tras el 24
de febrero sin embargo medusa logró
mantener una audiencia de millones de
personas en el país creo que esta
decisión Está directamente relacionada
con esto creo que las autoridades
estaban extremadamente frustradas de que
medusa continuará operando conservando
su audiencia a los periodistas en Rusia
y continuará ofreciendo una amplia
cobertura de los acontecimientos rusos
bien y por razones de seguridad la
redacción de medusa Pide a cualquiera
que esté en Rusia o planee viajar a
Rusia que borre cualquier post vinculado
a medusa y sin embargo para las personas
que ni sean rusas ni vivan en territorio
ruso ni tengan previsto viajar
Próximamente a Rusia pide colaboración
ya sea financiera o de otro tipo no y
finalmente en un comunicado que han
publicado hoy en su página web señalan
que como más nos presionen más
resistiremos el título de este
comunicado es si quieren pelea tendrán
pelea bueno bastante fuerte este
comunicado Rosa gracias por toda esta
información y este repaso a la prensa
internacional Gracias a ti María Clara
hasta pronto Hasta pronto